Moment. Du hast kein Mikro an.
Entschuldigung. Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Emre Göktas. Ich bin der zuständige Arzt für Sie.
Bevor wir anfangen, lassen Sie mich bitte zuerst Ihre persönliche Daten notieren.
Wenn Sie jetzt etwas nicht verstehen oder wenn Sie Fragen haben,
bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid oder fragen Sie nach. Okay? Alles klar. Wie heißen Sie? Ich heiße Kevin
Jäger. Könnten Sie bitte Ihr Vor- und Nachnamen stabilieren? Ja, der Vorname ist Kevin mit K-E-V-I-N.
Okay. Und der Familienname ist Jäger mit J-A-Umlaut-G-E-R. Gut. Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Jäger?
Ich bin 18 Jahre. 18. Wann genau sind Sie geboren? Am 12.09.2003.
Okay. Wie viel wiegen Sie? Ich wiege 67 Kilo. Und wie groß sind Sie? 1,80 m. Wo wohnen Sie?
Ich wohne, ja, wo auch immer. Da wo du aufwohnt. Okay. Was sind Sie? Schuhe oder?
Ich bin in der Ausbildung zum technischen Zeichner. Okay. Also ich muss auch in die Berufsschule noch gehen,
aber bin sonst in der Firma halt. Okay. Ich denke, Sie sind Single, oder? Ja, ich bin nicht verheiratet,
ich wohne aber mit meiner Freundin zusammen. Okay. Und haben Sie Kinder? Nein, nein.
Okay. Ja, Herr Jäger, was kann ich für Sie gründen? Ja, also ich bin unzufrieden, weil ich seit drei Wochen nicht schlecht fühle.
Und das hat natürlich langsam angefangen, aber ich habe auch immer erhöhte Temperatur.
Das Schlucken tut mir weh und ich bin total schlapp. Ich habe Kopfschmerzen und auch Bauchschmerzen.
Hier oben links tut es mir weh im Bauch und ja, weil das jetzt schon so lange geht, habe ich gedacht,
jetzt muss ich doch endlich mal zum Arzt gehen. Okay. Sie fühlen sich schlecht und diese Beschwerden
langsam angefangen und Sie haben auch erhöhte Temperatur und Schluckenprobleme
und Bauchschmerzen, oder? Genau, ja. Okay. Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden? Ja, das hat vor drei Wochen angefangen.
Okay. Wann haben Sie ihr Fieber gemessen? Und wie? Ja, immer mal morgens unterm Arm.
Okay. Wie viel war die Temperatur? Ja, das schwankt so zwischen 38 und 38, fünf so in dem Drehen.
Okay. Haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenommen? Nein, ich habe gedacht, das muss eigentlich wieder weggen.
Ich habe dann mal wegen der Kopfschmerzen, habe ich mal Parazita-Mol genommen, aber das hat irgendwie auch nicht so richtig durchschlagen, besser gemacht.
Okay. Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben Bauchschmerzen, können Sie mir sagen, wo genau die Schmerzen sind?
Ja, eigentlich nicht so unterbauf, sondern mehr so im Oberbau. Und wenn ich überlege, so mehr auf der linken Seite.
Okay. Und wie sind diese Schmerzen? Sind sie eher dumpf oder stechens oder brennend?
Ich würde eher sagen, dumpf. Du drückend irgendwie. Okay. Und strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hin aus?
Nein, Jess, es ist mir jetzt nicht so aufgefallen. Okay.
Und diese Beschwerden haben vor drei Wochen aufgetreten, sind aufgetreten und sind sie dauerhaft oder geht sie wieder weg?
Eigentlich ist das schon dauerhaft. Also mal ein bisschen weniger, mal ein bisschen mehr.
Manchmal denke ich, ach, ja, heute geht es mir wieder besser. Aber dann, wenn ich irgendwas versucht habe zu machen, was weiß ich, in den Weg zu erledigen oder so, dann habe ich gleich gemerkt, dass ich eigentlich doch nicht so gut drauf bin.
Okay. Und die Bauchschmerzen?
Sie sind wie, oder die Schmerzinsenste? Okay.
Wie viel die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 0 bis 10? 0 ist keine Schmerzen, 10 ist starke Schmerzensinn.
Ja, so ganz schlimm sind die nicht. Das ist mehr so unterschwellig. Ich würde vielleicht sagen bei 5.
Bei 5.
Viel bis 5, ja.
Okay. Wissen Sie, haben Sie bemerkt, ob diese Beschwerden etwas lindert oder verstärkt?
Ja, wenn ich Ruhe gebe, dann geht es mir ein bisschen besser. Also ich muss mich halt schon irgendwie, aber das ist ja nichts in meinem Alter.
Ich kann da nicht mit 18 Jahren nur rumhängen in der Gegend. Ich muss da wieder arbeiten und muss in die Schule gehen und muss Sport machen.
Und das geht irgendwie alles gar nicht im Augenblick, weil ich viel zu schlapp bin.
Okay. Aber im Ruhe haben Sie keine Probleme, ja?
Ja.
Dann geht es mir ein bisschen besser. Der Kopfschmerzen habe ich dann schon auch wohl und Schluckbeschwerden, aber irgendwie kann man es besser aushalten, wenn ich mich schonen, ne?
Okay.
Okay, haben Sie Fieber? Ja, Sie haben für eine Entschuldigung.
Ja, habe ich schon.
Gut, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit, sind Sie in der letzten Zeit gereist, in meiner, im Ausland, oder?
Nee, im Ausland war ich nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Bewegung von Nackenbereich?
Ne.
Ja, ich merke, dass die Lymphkloppen so ein bisschen geschwollen sind. Das spüre ich wohl, ja.
Ja, ich schulde.
Okay.
Haben Sie, läuft Ihr Nase in der letzten Zeit?
Nein, nur bei Kälte eigentlich, wenn ich rausgehe oder so, aber jetzt nicht auffällig.
Müssen Sie niesen in der letzten Zeit?
Ne, schnupfen habe ich nicht, ne?
Okay.
Haben Sie erbrochen?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Übel in dem eigentlichen Sinne so, nee, das eigentlich nicht.
Ich fühle mich nicht gut, aber Übelkeit so, dass es wie von Magen kommt, nee, so, das ist das nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Ne, eigentlich nicht, aber also, was ich habe, das habe ich aber eigentlich immer schon, dass ich ziemlich leicht Blähungen habe.
Aber das ist jetzt nicht anders als sonst.
Blähungen.
Okay.
Müssen Sie in der letzten Zeit mehrmals, müssen Sie in der letzten Zeit sauer aufstoßen?
Ne.
Okay.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Gewicht verloren oder zunehmen, zugenommen?
Ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen, ne?
Haben Sie Kribbelgefühl oder Taubheitsgefühl im Beine oder im Arme oder in den Finger?
Nein.
Okay.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen, zum aktuellen Anamnese, aktuellen Beschwerden?
Nee, das ist, ich habe Ihnen glaube ich jetzt so alles erzählt, was mir im Augenblick zu schaffen macht, ja.
Jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Vorgeschichte etwas fragen. Leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen wie Bluthochdruck oder Diabetes, Zuckerkrankungen oder Herzerkrankungen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Okay.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Nee, das nicht.
Okay.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie schwere oder chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, tatsächlich, da sind einige Geschichten. Mein Vater ist tatsächlich ganz früh gestorben, der hat den Schildrüsenkrebs und meine Mutter hat Diabetes und hat schon jetzt Probleme mit den Augen.
Das ist nicht so toll.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich bin ein Einzelkind.
Okay.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Normalerweise.
Nicht so wirklich gut. Eigentlich schlafe ich eher nicht so gut.
Seit wann schlafen Sie sich nicht gut? Seit drei Wochen oder vorher?
Nee, schon länger eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ne, denen Sie sich gut?
Na ja, also soweit das geht, neben der Schule und neben der Arbeit. Ich bin das kein Profikoch und meine Freundin auch nicht.
Aber doch, also wir versuchen schon, uns annähernd gesund zu ernähren.
Okay, aber Ihr Appetit ist normal.
Ja, ich habe ich Hunger, ja.
Gut.
Gibt es etwas, was Sie seelig belastet?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Gut, nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, also regelmäßig eigentlich nicht.
Ich habe nur, weil wir darf eben, wenn ich Schmerzen habe, nämlich dann Paracetamol.
Wie viele Milligramm haben Sie eingenommen?
Oh, ich weiß gar nicht, was da drauf steht.
Kann aber sein, dass das 500 war, ja.
Und dann habe ich tatsächlich so eine Lichtallergie, so eine Sonnenallergie, da bin ich da, der Sonne, also insbesondere im Gesicht und an den Händen.
Und wenn ich da nicht vorsichtig war, dann muss ich manchmal so Cortisonsalbe auftragen.
Dann kriege ich so einen Ausschlag davon.
Und da hilft dann nur noch Cortisonsalbe.
Okay.
Rauchen Sie?
Hin und wieder mal eine Zigarette, aber ich bin kein richtiger Raucher.
Okay, was meinen Sie hin und wieder? Wie oft rauchen Sie?
Ja, vielleicht dreimal im Monat eine Zigarette oder so, also wirklich nur so, wenn aus Geselligkeit oder so.
Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, genau das gleiche. Also mal am Wochenende ein Bier oder wenn man fest ist, dass man mal etwas trinkt, aber nicht regelmäßig.
Okay.
Außer Sonnenallergie haben Sie sonstige Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit?
Ja, ich habe so Heuschnupfen.
Ich habe so Schnupfen, dass ich auf Gräserpollen und so etwas allergespinnen.
Dann trennen die Augen und dann läuft auch die Nase, dann habe ich auch richtig Schnupfen.
Gut.
Meineseits habe ich die wichtigste Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie Probleme, haben Sie Fragen oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, was vielleicht noch interessant sein könnte für Sie, ich habe erzählt, ich wohne mit meiner Freundin zusammen und die hat eigentlich ganz ähnlich hier Beschwerden.
Und da, die wollte ich jetzt auch mal zum Arzt gehen irgendwann, aber haben wir uns da vielleicht irgendwie mit etwas angesteckt, das ist die Frage.
Und natürlich, wissen Sie, mein Vater ist eben so sehr früh gestorben, da hat man natürlich schon auch ein bisschen Sorge, gerade wenn da so ein geschwollener Lymphknoten ist, dass man sagt, hey, was ist das, ist das irgendwie eine schlimme Erkrankung?
Ja, ihr Vater hat ein Schildrusenkrebs, aber diese Beschwerden bedeuten nicht genau, dass sie auch diese Kranken haben.
Wir haben ja erst mal die weitere Untersuchungen durchführen, aber Sie haben gesagt, Ihre Freundin hat auch ähnliche Beschwerden.
Hat sie zum Arzt gegangen?
Ja, sie wollte jetzt die nächsten Tage auch gehen.
Dann haben Sie zusammen etwas umgewöhnliches gegessen oder abproben?
Nee, also, das wäre ja auch irgendwie, wenn uns übel gewesen wäre, wenn uns schlecht gewesen wäre nach dem Essen oder so, das hätte man ja irgendwie zuordnen können.
Nein.
Okay.
Okay, dann, jetzt möchte ich Sie körperlich untersuchen und ich möchte auch Blut abnehmen.
Und ich würde gerne auch die Röntgen, Bauchröntgen antworten und gegebenenfalls kann ich auch die Ultraschall durchführen.
Okay?
Ja.
Nach der Ergebnisse natürlich besprechen wir weiter wieder.
Okay, gut.
Gibt es Fragen von den Kollegen?
Ja, wir können vielleicht überlugen, etwas sprechen, höchstens oder atemnord oder andere Beschwerde-Übelung.
Das erste Wort habe ich nicht verscheinert, über?
Lunge.
Aber die Lunge ist jetzt, habe ich es kapiert, sorry, ja, okay, hatte ich akustisch nicht verstanden.
Nee, Husten muss der eigentlich nicht.
Er hat Schluckbeschwerden, ne?
Ich habe Schluckbeschwerden, Genaubischwerden, beim Werken Essen, haben wir Schluckbeschwerden.
Nur Trinken oder?
Ne, eigentlich, eigentlich immer, eigentlich immer, ja.
Wobei kalte Flüssigkeiten gehen natürlich immer am besten, da tut es nicht so sehr weh, aber eigentlich tut es beim Schlucken immer weh.
Und wie viele Lisknoten sind Ihnen ausgefahren?
Eine oder multiple oder?
Ich würde sagen mehr als einer, zwei, weiß ich, wo die so überall sitzen, aber zwei hier am Hals sind mir aufgefallen, ja.
Wenn Sie drücken, tut das weh?
Ja, okay.
Emre, hast du keine Idee?
Nein.
Echt nicht?
Bauchschmerzen, Kopfschmerzen, eine, natürlich eine impikziose Krankheit.
Aber Kopfschmerzen, Kopfschmerzen und Schluckprobleme und Lampfknoten vor drei Leuten.
Junge Leute, beide impiziert, ja.
Beide?
Impifiziert?
Ja, die Freude hat ja die gleichen Symptome.
Gastro, nee, nicht.
Akutonzillitis oder warum? Sie haben Bauchschmerzen.
Ja, dann machen wir doch vielleicht mal das Arztgespräch.
Okay, machen wir.
Okay, guten Tag.
Wollten wir, der kommt noch mit der Dr. Alici will noch was sagen?
Ja.
Nee, jetzt hat er wieder ausgesprochen.
Nachher, nachher.
Nachher, gut, okay.
Ich glaube, er gibt mir ein Tipp.
Eigentlich kam gerade ein Tipp schon.
Ich schriftlich kam gerade ein Tipp.
Ja.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob du das gesehen hast.
Gut, wir gucken.
Ach so, ja.
Okay.
So, guten Tag Frau Oberärztin.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie Grundzeit?
Ja, natürlich.
Okay, es geht um Kevin Jäger.
Er ist 18 Jahre alt, 67 Kilo, 180 Zentimeter groß.
Er wohnt mit seiner Freundin.
Er fühlt sich schlecht vor drei Wochen.
Seit drei Wochen hat er höchste Temperatur.
Er hat 38,5 C°C gemessen.
Er hat auch Schlucksturungen, dysphagie und Abdominalschmerzen
und Kopfschmerzen.
Er hat dagegen 500 Milligramm Paracetamol eingenommen.
Aber das hat ihm nicht geholfen.
Abdominalschmerzen liegt im Epigastrikbereich.
Der Oberarzt ist dumpf.
Die Beschwerden sind dauerhaft.
Die Beschwerden gehen im Ruhe besser.
Er hat gemerkt, dass er geschwollene Blämpfknoten hat.
Er hat Blähungen.
Er hat die Arö und Omitus verneint.
Er schläft nicht gut.
Er nimmt 500 Milligramm Paracetamol.
Er hat Sonnenallergie und benutzt die Korotison Salbe.
Er raucht dreimal im Monat.
Er trinkt am Wochenende Gelegenheit Bier.
Er hat Fotodermatose und allergische Renitis gegen Gräser und Ollen.
Was ist Ihre Anlage?
Nach den bisherigen Angaben gehe ich von Epstein-Barwürzeln aus.
Was könnte es noch sein?
Manengitis und Acuponcilitis.
Schlechtes Fall?
Leidungs-Kazinom?
Was machen Sie jetzt mit dem Diagnostik?
Die körperliche Untersuchung ist sehr wichtig.
Was erwarten Sie?
Die Milz ist verhärtet.
Was machen Sie labortechnisch?
Die Entzündung der Parameter ist wichtig.
Was haben Sie mit dem Antikörper bestätigt?
Es gibt einen Schnelltest für Mononucleaere-Lymphozyten.
Die Antikörper gegen Epstein-Bar und Virus.
Was ist die Therapie?
Die Antikörper gegen Fieber.
Was machen Sie mit dem Antikörper gegen Schmerzen?
Wir brauchen eine Quarantiner-Isolation.
Der muss sich schonen.
Warum muss man Belastung vermeiden?
Er hat eine Medizin und muss vermeiden Trauma.
Hier steht es so schön symptomatisch.
Dann war noch eine Prüfernachfrage.
Er hat ein erhöhtes Risiko beim Vater.
Er hat keine genetischen Prädispositionen.
Er hat eine Vergrößerung der Milz.
Ich habe gelesen.
Er ist ein junger Mann.
Er hat viele Risikofaktoren.
Er hat zwei speziellen Namen.
Er ist unter jungen Leuten.
Er ist ein junger Mann.
Er hat viele andere Karsinom auftreten.
Er hat keine genetische Erkrankungen.
Vielen Dank.